let's jump to this next story from
deadline because we've got good news and
I'm really excited uh to to cover the
story Jim caviezel's anti-child
trafficking Thriller sound of Freedom
not just 10 million dollar pre-sales
before July 4th and then we have this
sound of freedom and Indiana Jones duke
it out on July 4th for the number one
spot check this out
Indiana Jones had
11.698 million
over sound of freedoms 11.5 million
sound of sound of Freedom was only a
couple hundred thousand dollars away
from being the number one film on the
4th of July
there's a lot to consider here
Indiana Jones made 83.7 million over the
weekend so most people who wanted to see
the new Indiana Jones saw it over the
weekend
people aren't going to watch it twice on
the 4th of July but still the fact that
an indie film is rivaling a major
release only a few days later is
tremendous
y'all should go see this movie for two
big for two reasons it's really good
I think half the theater was crying for
the first 45 minutes there's some really
great story writing in there really
awesome stuff I'm not going to spoil and
the second reason is to help Foster that
parallel economy supporting indie films
that are outside of Hollywood so that
industry can compete and flourish and we
can push back against this garbage is
extremely important I got some questions
about sound of Freedom you saw it
absolutely is using a documentary no
okay does it Thriller talk about oh does
it talk about the Cobalt mines in Africa
no okay so it is specifically the story
of Timothy Ballard who was a uh U.S law
enforcement Homeland Security and how he
quit his job to go and rescue kids who
are being trafficked and it is brutal
and GM plays Jim Caviezel plays Ballard
you know you're like like
man everybody in the theater was crying
like non-stop throughout the for the
first 45 minutes and then again like 10
minutes later there's Parts where you
get happy because the heroes are winning
you stop crying and then it goes back to
what's going on in this world and you
just like fighting back tears you know
what a lot of you know say what you will
about him he's a guy with obviously some
flaws but Mel Gibson this is his film
this is his isn't it I don't know he's
one of my favorite actors of all time I
love him Mel come over yeah I know he's
working on a documentary about uh I
think it's about Ukraine and trafficking
and stuff like this but I don't know I'm
kind of worried about wanting to go to
going to see this and then walking out
of the theater wanting to go like hunt
down pedophiles or something and being
like so but charge for that but that's
the point of the film and by hunt down
the correct answer is support legitimate
organizations that team up with
international law enforcement to bring
these people down this is what Ballard's
organization does it's it's you want to
stop these pedos and these traffickers
and you want you want to get involved in
that you watch this movie and afterwards
that's that's exactly what I was
thinking I was like how are we not
putting more money into stopping what's
going on because these it is it is it is
nightmarish this it looks like Mel
Gibson is not attached to this film as
far as I can tell Edward Eduardo Vera is
the producer and we have Alejandro Monte
Verde is the director written by Rod
Barr and Alejandro himself Monteverde so
I don't think Mel is attached to this
like what ages do you for those
wondering what uh which ages do you
think would be appropriate to see this
oh 18 and up really I mean what's the
what's the rating on the movie actually
According to Jim because he's old Mel
Gibson did weep when he saw the movie oh
bro like everyone in theaters that's
what I was talking about I everyone
everyone in the theater was crying I I
was I I will say this I was on the verge
of tears and you know
I just fought him back fought him back
but everyone around me is crying
uh what was the rating I'm looking it up
I don't see what what the movie was
rated because uh
nothing it doesn't show anything
explicit
but it's heavily implied like you know
what's happening there's a scene where
there's a little girl in the bed and a
creepy guy walks in and then it shows
out the window and he closes the blinds
like you get it a kid would understand
what was going on but adult would I
don't think you want to bring kids to
this movie you know this and it's such a
universally repulsive thing that this
movie attacks and go after like even in
prison you know you hear stories the
people that get it worse that every the
worst criminals in the world will turn
on is the people that get sent to prison
for abusing children so it's just it's
like a universal thing at least in our
cultures this is the lowest of the
lowest of the low end
I think the point of this film is it's
not really being taken as seriously as
it should how do you really it's PG-13
wow how do you redeem the people like
that pedophiles how do you redeem
pedophile how do you make them no longer
pedophiles yeah
it's the hardest thing obviously I'm not
talking about like well no no they they
they they I I'm I'm fairly certain that
they found recidive recidivism among
child abusers is like that's the worst
part and then it's the people that have
been abused as kids grow up and then
they think either it's okay because it
happened to them or there's some sort of
weird so like breaking that cycle is
what Humanity needs to do without
because we can't just kill ourselves off
and stop it that way that's not
effective you arrest them well that's
one way you can you can slow it down I
gotta tell you I want to say this
when I was watching this movie
I started having a whole bunch of
thoughts about the moral philosophy of
Crime and Punishment and the appropriate
Solutions and how you deal with these
people because there's a lot of people
that have advocated for the death
penalty for uh traffickers especially
and for pedophiles you watch this movie
and you'll go
I completely understand the moral
position the issue is and I'm watching
this movie
this I I don't want to spoil anything
but let me just tell you
there's no mustache twirling villain
there's not a guy who's like we're
taking kids it's like the scary thing is
the banality of it the guy who grabs
little girl and throws her in an attack
in in a in a cargo box and then gets
handed an envelope of cash and walks
away like nothing happened the
Simplicity the horror of it I thought to
myself what is the punishment for
destroying Humanity in this way
and I understand why people say that
through due process quite literally like
well I'm not going to play any stupid
games and and talk bravado like you
arrest them and then then they get
sentenced to death my fear is always the
death penalty is that innocent people
will get caught up in it and if one
percent of the people who are charged
are innocent put to death we have a very
very serious problem I side with the
founding fathers blackstone's
formulation but when you see this film
it really makes it difficult and I
thought to myself I don't think the
founding fathers understood the massive
scale of child sex trafficking and
slavery that would be happening when
they were alike we should be very very
concerned or maybe the reality is they
truly understood the depravity of evil
in this world and understood the
importance of innocent until proven
guilty and you know due process rights
but I gotta tell you
I don't know what the solution is but
when you see these crimes being
perpetrated
I I oh man
I just got to tell you I understand why
people advocate for amending the laws to
have the death penalty for child
exploitation you know one one place to
start would be to get our government to
stop perpetuating this because you know
that in Afghanistan this is kind of a
big part of that culture and the United
States went to war against a regime that
was very bad but did Outlaw this and we
Allied ourselves with one that
perpetuated and we had our own soldiers
suffering PTSD because their allies
would go into the next room and molest a
child and they were ordered not to do
anything about it right and then they
had to come back with that knowing that
they were protecting those people and
perpetuating that government and they
still have to live that and God knows
what the children over there have to go
through there is a scene man I really
don't want to spoil this movie but let
me just tell you
so you can understand without spoiling
the film
this is about an undercover operation oh
man what do you think a person in an
under I I shouldn't I shouldn't frame
like this he doesn't the the main
character never does anything untoward
but when you're in law enforcement
like in the beginning of the movie he's
doing his job he has to review evidence
and it's just like him crying the whole
time and I'm just like
there's a scene in the trailer so it's
not a spoiler where a guy's like I
cannot do this job and he like walks off
it's like yeah dude who could I'm
surprised there's anybody who could
stand that but if nobody does that job
these evil people get away with it and
may turn other people into
evil people that's the worst part about
it is it affects children when they're
young and then it can twist them early
and and dude the writing is so good
I I like I want to spoil the movie so
big so I want to tell you just how good
it was but I can't I gotta wait I gotta
wait I had a fantasy about interviewing
Charles Manson before he died because I
thought if we can somehow get through to
the worst of the worst and let them tell
their story and you see why they became
that way maybe that's like a step
towards antidote you don't think someone
like Manson actually has like
is sick because I I think that there are
some people that are that have mental
illness that are really really sick and
they need they need to be taken out of
regular Society not be not because I
want to want them to or I because I
think that that they deserve to be
punished or whatever but because they're
actually sick there are medications that
do help there are people that if they
don't take their medication they do
behave in ways that are unacceptable
they harm themselves they'll harm other
people so I don't know I don't know that
I agree with like
with with the idea that you can figure
out what's wrong and just love them back
to health I think it's there's a lot of
mental illness that is really really
really sick people that really need the
medications well and he's right and he's
he's right for an even bigger reason
you and him you know being on the edge
of Tears watching that movie The reason
you're on the edge of Tears the reason
it makes you upset and angry is because
you have something that is called
empathy and empathy requires your
ability to map somebody else's mind to
sort of simulate what they are feeling
what they're experiencing some people do
not have the capability to do that it
usually tracks with like being lower
intelligence that's why you have so many
criminals they're also not very
intelligent the reason is that they
don't have the ability to think about
how another person would feel rece on
the receiving end of their behavior they
don't know how to do unto others as you
let to do under yourself they have no
idea how to imagine how anybody else
would feel they'll punch you in the face
without thinking about it because it
never what prevents us in many ways from
doing evil things gosh if somebody did
that to me I would be horrified that
would be and you empathize so these
people don't have the ability to do that
and it's not something you can really
create thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for on censored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time